so here you're going to brian wilson's
house
and he opens up the door what does he
start singing your song right he's
thinking
and you can tell that i hope you don't
mind i hope you don't mind i hope you
don't mind
i'm standing there and i'm going oh my
god um you know i'm so quaking in my
boots anyway
and it was it was an extraordinarily
eccentric night because
that was when he was leaving the house
with the sand in the dining room with
the piano
and i went there on the um assumption
that i was going to hear a 16 track or
the eight track of
good vibrations and we finally got
around to doing it and he would start
playing and then he was
10 seconds into the song no it's not the
right mix so we didn't really
get to hear the whole good vibrations
and we were sitting there it was 2
o'clock in the morning i'd never been up
that late for a long time
but it was just being in the presence of
someone like that because there's been
films about it and he was strange i'd
never experienced anything like that in
my life
but it just came it's like wow we just
saw brian moss but he was kind he was
lovely
and he always has been to me and i love
him so much i still do i love brian
and then he tried to sell me the piano
um in the
in the in the sandbox and i go with
bernie
left and go oh my god we're from you
know if i mean we never seen anything
like this but it was truly fantastic
it's like playing charades with bob
dylan but um neil diamond's house and
the next time he went to la
and bob was on my team um and i'm very
competitive and bob really couldn't
there yeah bob the greatest lyricist
fantastic and
three words together that no one else
can but can't do sounds like in two
syllables
and so i'm getting really [ __ ] off and
it's like we're losing i'm going and i
apparently i threw oranges at him and
um tangerine and my friend tony king who
was there
and bringing me up the next day i said
darling do you remember throwing oranges
at bob dylan last night i went oh [ __ ]
um the thing that blew my mind that you
said
you're just becoming really big somehow
you end up at a party with neil younger
he's at your house
and he says i want to play you my new
album and he takes out his guitar i
guess
and and and does the complete album
harvest
in front of you on the piano
i went to see in the raw festival hall
he came back to the apartment and he
played again because the neighbors
complained but i wasn't going to
shut him up was i i mean i didn't know
he has always been another person who's
always been so great to me and so sweet
um
and we went out in honolulu one night
and got really really
really really drunk we went to a great
restaurant and i'm i started doing
hey hey [ __ ] creek fairy uh
over dinner well i probably shouldn't
have done but anyway he's got to go then
then he bring me up the next morning at
the cracker door went
goodbye